auswirkung von egbert yuan
kannst du mir mal einen teller geben
all das hier sind die gleichen sachen
blog kategorie küchen koch hex mit live
acts mit luca weber
das war es
jetzt
übrigens heute morgen schon in der stadt
und mit einem dönerladen her gefahren
es ist 13 uhr auf jeden fall haben wir
auf ihrem döner einfach rucola angeboten
da merkst dass du in hamburg ist eine
sache die welt und ich übrigens extrem
kraft hat man der wohnung ist das hier
du musst ja immer so gegen taschen damit
der kühlschrank aufgeht anja offen hier
aber wenn ich dir stehe und puppe komme
ich mit dem krieg
unter den gta und dann noch die
waschmaschine die hat wlan
perfekt übrigens ich das früher von
ferrari
weil das so gut ist aber da müssen wir
mal aufgefallen das ist halt ferrero
heißt
gedacht auch noch das drk eigentlichen
arzt sei
ich habe auch früher gedacht dass sobald
man 100 ist stirbt man einfach
runter ganze aktuelle situation weltweit
sind die spritpreise übrigens
mittlerweile so hoch dass man über zwei
euro pro liter bezahlt du fährst quasi
zur arbeit um geld zu verdienen um
tanken zu können um zur arbeit zu fahren
um geld zu verdienen um tanken zu können
um geht es mal der eltern 26 jahren
hatten sich so gedacht mensch das haus
kaufen wir jetzt dazu haben wir zwei
kinder drin und ich
mit 26 sitzen auf dem klo abgepackt es
wäre noch kein grund jetzt muss ich mein
hut nehmen
liebe grüße
das funktioniert richtig los sagt
nichts bei dir
da man hat sich sommersprossen ins
gesicht gemalt
es sieht aus als hätte jemand die
spaghetti sieht in die fresse gekappt
warum
es gibt übrigens kein gallerin geruch
als benzin gerochen in seiner garage
nach benzin riecht
es mich auch kurzfilm und wahrsagen
warten
die sonne lacht und der strand ruft mit
den knall wahre christen sunny sie
stellen kannst du die sonne nach dem
spielen mit in die badewanne nehme
sie der voraussetzung dass diese gewalt
im letzten block haben wir uns gefragt
ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt warum
unterschied gemacht zwischen grünem
rasen weiß klaus blau die oecd holly
hier drunter kommentiert das deswegen
recycling getrennt wird weil dann alle
grünen flaschen beispielsweise
geschmolzen werden und zum neuen grünen
flaschen verarbeitet werden
[Musik]
wie geht die prothese mit möhren an alle
die sagen können gerne rein bitte direkt
nicht
und dann weiter geht vorbei an dem wir
keine einzige matheformeln gebraucht
haben
alles kaputt das heißt ich muss jetzt
neun stockwerke zu fuß laufen
1 weil ich bin die nummer eins im
eisblock
extra die kamera dahingestellt damit ich
damit einfacher da hoch sind heute
morgen haben wir das wenn ihr noch so
sehr dass er alles einfach drei mal seht
für mich sind das 70 taxi ist klar louis
gerade fahrrad falls es noch einmal
aufgefallen dass hamburg ist auf solche
fake statt alter die sonne scheint du
denkst es war eisig teil erst mal ein
bisschen sightseeing polizei
darf ich filme auf dem fahrrad keine
ahnungslosen auf dem vermögen hier ist
jungfernstieg das ist jetzt geschichte
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was
die sich bei dieser bepo hier gedacht
haben
dass ich einfach nur gottlos beschissen
aus wie es apple store jungfernstieg
hlinka immer der treffpunkt man sagt
eigentlich immer dass die jungfernstieg
apple
achtzigern ich bin zu müde das raten
muss auf jeden fall mein fahrrad hatten
planen
und ist dass die scheiße dem
elektrofahrrad ist kein laden dafür das
ding da vorne ihr aufpusten außer
aufpusten wahrscheinlich auch nur
elektrofahrrad leben dürfen das machen
und ich muss jetzt meinen fahrrad mit
dem handy abschließend alter diese ganze
technik heutzutage hier war sandra auf
jeden fall unterwegs um hier seht ihr
noch mal das rathaus
solchen terminen alles wirkt übrigens
ich das tun was die baggies als die
vergütung den ghettos
tommy nennt man es wenn hinter dem zug
dampf aufsteigt
auch abzug
nennt man es wenn in einer clique so
eine schlechte lage gerade ist das ist
die
notausgänge kommt jetzt kommt auch noch
leute alter
hat jemand irgendwann hab ich wirklich
so die hände gewaschen mal wenn ich in
apotheke bin laufe ich da durch und
denke mir nur so jedes dieser produkte
könnte ich gebraucht scheiße wandhalter
ich glaube ich auch ein problem habe
schön für mich weniger hageln fc stars
kalt scheiße ich finds ja irgendwie süß
aber irgendwie total opfer wenn er
seinen mantel tragen ich war gerade in
so einem fahrradladen bin einfach
reingegangen und meint ich habe platten
vorne kannst du vielleicht kurz darauf
machen um das
opfer das sind diese leute
die sind viel zu sehr in ihren dingen
darin dass sie so die sind einfach das
sind so leute die gegen alles sind was
fortschrittlich ist das laut ich schwöre
ich mal wenn ich von kölns der
amokfahrer fühle ich mich wie new york
aber jetzt zurück zu den typen alter ich
mache mir einfach noch mal luft oft
meinen reifen mit dem e-bike ist aber
nicht gern gesehen in ernste neben den
fahrradläden ja brauchst mir scheißegal
alter ich wäre viel zu faul zu treten
alter ich will nicht eure fahrradkultur
da kaputt machen mit wasserstoff anhalt
damit sowas egal fitness tun offentlich
jetzt auch mal machen könnt ihr jetzt
mal sanft aufwerten
hier möglicher neuer live act von mir
übrigens immer daran denken wenn er
rausgeht dass eine packung taschentücher
mitnimmt weil es gibt nichts nervige
riss als wenn du dann irgendwie
naseputzen musst du hast genießt oder
musst du deine maske zum beispiel
schmerzen weil das hatte ich mal
hatte schon eine maske und da musste ich
die wieder aufziehen das hat ziemlich
entwürdigen distanz nicht mehr sehen
hauptsache im letzten block habe ich
noch alle hamburger für ihren komischen
wolfram jeans und
die genau diese sache den ganzen
hamburger häuser blenden einfach richtig
wenn die sonne scheint
so wie ich das wirklich geisteskrank wie
alles in dieser stadt einfach tausend
mal schöner satz in köln hier sehen wir
wieder zwei mülltonnen auf einem foto
frag mich aus welchem land sie kommen
richtig lasse sich auch so drauf das ist
einmal der kleinste fast in hamburg
sind einfach nur so zehn treppenstufen
immer dann hoch kommst du wird sind
trotzdem jedes mal neben glaube ich an
und ich bin jetzt lotto
[Musik]
wir sind auf jeden fall die
schlechtesten lotto spieler der welt ist
es noch nicht
vielleicht gewinnen wir auch aber
einfach von kreuzer einmal habe ich
immer zwei fällen
keine ahnung was jetzt gekauft haben
neun euro 15 aber vielleicht sind die
beiden millionäre reizwäsche übrigens
frage wo wir hin laufen das wissen wir
selber nicht
retten sucht irgendwo einen schattigen
platz um fotos machen wie nennt man keks
im schatten schattiges plätzchen
[Musik]
nur damit das klar ist ein eingehender
anruf von sandra also die hat mich
angerufen ich sags ja die gibt mich
[Musik]
das deutsche reinheitsgebot okay du den
baum hier würde ich übrigens niemals
parken dann das jetzt ordentlich zu
beschützen wir waren gerade auf unser
taxi und das ist echt beschissen
deswegen also
[Musik]
jetzt
sagte dass ein zeichen wir holen die
millionen wie werden echt fett
ich kann ja so viele talente gar nichts
[Musik]
wir haben es verpasst aber wir schauen
uns jetzt die zahlen auf youtube an und
dann können wir millionär gleich
damals einfach ein youtube-video mehr
warum ich musste intel erst darauf
wissen
ziehung der lottozahlen vom neunten 32
01 22 macht sogar schon ärzte und
ja so leid ist nicht meine strombach
nein ich halte so richtig zeigen wegen
rechten und linken
10 millionen 18 millionen natürlich aus
wenn man keine frage nach sinn dass
keine hausnummer ist doch so wenn jetzt
nicht lange straße
hier kommt das unsere erste plan
und das ist die
88 10 19 28 36 38 und diesem fall ist er
an der stelle kann man einfach nur sagen
glücksspiele scheiße
machen sie wieder wir sind beide neuen
euro ärmer
macht es nicht leute ihr habt es gerade
selber gesehen es ist einfach nur
geldverschwendung es ist einfach scheiße
das muss man so sagen und meine blogs
und auch scheiß deswegen macht es jetzt
auch aus